DEATHS.
AND AS THE BATTLE AGAINST
COVID-19 APPEARS TO BE REACHING
A CRITICAL STAGE.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAYING
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT CITIES,
INCLUDING NEW YORK, DETROIT, AND
NEW ORLEANS, COULD SEE
INFECTIONS PEAK IN THE COMING
DAYS.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NEARLY
338,000 CORONAVIRUS CASES IN THE
UNITED STATES, WITH AT LEAST
9600 DEATHS.
AT THE PRESIDENT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE WORN THE WEEK AHEAD
COULD BE DEVASTATING.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
HARDEST AND THE SADDEST WEEK OF
MOST AMERICANS’ LIVES, QUITE
FRANKLY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR
PEARL HARBOR MOMENT, OUR 9/11
MOMENT.
>> I WOULD NOT SAY WE HAVE IT
UNDER CONTROL.
THAT WOULD BE A FALSE STATEMENT.
WE ARE STRUGGLING TO GET IT
UNDER CONTROL, AND THAT THE
ISSUE THAT’S AT HAND RIGHT NOW.
>> THIS WILL BE PROBABLY THE
TOUGHEST WEEK, BETWEEN THIS
BEGIN NEXT WEEK.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF DEATHS,
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Melissa: THIS IS
"OUTNUMBERED" AND I’M
MELISSA FRANCIS.
HERE TODAY IS HARRIS FAULKNER.
HOST OF "KENNEDY" ON
FOX BUSINESS, KENNEDY IS BACK
WITH US.
WELCOME, MY FRIEND.
EMILY COMPAGNO IS JOINING US, AS
WELL.
AND DR. MARTY MAKARY, PHYSICIAN
AND PROFESSOR AT JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY AND A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
AND HE IS "OUTNUMBERED."
DR. MAKARY, WHERE DO
YOU THINK WE ARE IN THIS?
DO YOU SEE ANY GLIMMERS OF HOPE?
>> Dr. Makary: I DO, BUT I
WOULD CAUTION AGAINST PEOPLE
OVER INTERPRETING ONE NUMBER
LOOKING BETTER OVER THE COURSE
OF ONE OR TWO DAYS.
WE SAW THIS IN ITALY WHEN WE GOT
EXCITED THAT THEIR NUMBERS HAD
GONE DOWN FROM, SAY, 500 TO 430.
IT TURNS OUT THE NUMBERS ARE
BEST LOOKED AT AS A THREE-DAY
MOVING AVERAGE.
I WOULDN’T OVER INTERPRET
THINGS.
I THINK SHELTERING IS WORKING.
I THINK WE ARE NOT SEEING THE
MASSIVE SPIKE THAT WAS POSSIBLE.
BUT I WOULD JUST BRACE FOR THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS TO BE A ROUGH
PERIOD.
NOT JUST THE NEXT WEEK.
KENNEDY, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Kennedy: I’M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT THE SPIKE DR. MAKARY IS
REFERRING TO HAS NOT HAPPENED.
BUT I AGREE, WE SHOULDN’T BE
FALSELY CONFIDENT, AND YOU HAVE
TO FIND THE JOY IN THE LITTLE
THINGS OF BEING QUARANTINED HAS
SHOWN US.
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION.
HE’S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, YOU CAN’T
JUST EXTRACT ONE NUMBER AND TAKE
THAT AS A SIGN THAT EVERYTHING
IS FINE.
OR ANOTHER NUMBER, AND USE THAT
AS A HYSTERICAL POINT TO FEAR
THAT YOU WILL BE STUCK INSIDE
FOREVER.
WE WILL COME THROUGH THIS AT
SOME POINT, AND A LITTLE BIT OF
GOOD NEWS IS GOING TO GO A LONG
WAY.
BUT WE SHOULD STILL SNUGGLE UP
AS THOUGH THERE IS A STORM UPON
US.
>> Melissa: YEAH.
EMILY, IT’S GOING TO BE
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT, I THINK,
AS TIME GOES ON.
AS DIFFERENT PARTS OF THIS
NATION ARE IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THIS CRISIS.
FOR SOME STATES, IT HASN’T
REALLY HIT THEM VERY HARD YET.
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK, MAYBE
WE’VE SEEN AN APEX AND WE ARE
GETTING CLOSE TO IT, OR WHATEVER
THE NUMBERS WILL SHOW US.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MEAN THAT IT’S
NOT GOING TO GET WORSE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS WE
RECOVER.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
V5 EXACTLY.
FOR EXAMPLE, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
PREDICTS ITS PEAK WILL COME IN
JUNE OR JULY.
SO THAT’S WHY I THINK FOR ALL OF
US SHELTERING IN PLACE AT HOME
IT’S IMPORTANT TO DO THIS SORT
OF AS A MARATHON, NOT A SPRINT.
WHILE WE SEE CERTAIN HOT JOAN’S
MAJOR
CITIES EXPERIENCE POTENTIALLY
THE APEX OR THE RAMP UP TO THE
APEX RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE OTHER
CITIES THAT ARE FRANKLY MONTHS
BEHIND.
IT’S A BOARD FOR ALL OF US, I
THINK.
AS KENNEDY SAID, TO SNUGGLE UP
AND STAY AT HOME.
BUT TO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS WILL RESOLVE
ITSELF IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO.
CONTRARY TO MANY OF OUR NEW
CYCLES OR NATIONAL
CONVERSATIONS, THAT LAST
SOMETIMES TWO OR THREE DAYS,
THIS IS REALLY A MONTHS-LONG
PROCESS.
THE BEST THING WE CAN DO FOR ALL
OF US IS STAY HOME IN THE
INTERIM WHILE, OBVIOUSLY,
RAMPING UP SUPPORT FOR THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITIES AND THE
DIFFERENT SURGING CITIES.
>> Melissa: HARRIS, I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR THOUGHTS.
ALSO, I MAY BE THE ONLY ONE, I’M
NOT HEARING DR. MAKARY.
SORRY TO AIR OUR BUSINESS HERE.
GO AHEAD, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS,
AND MAYBE YOU HAVE A QUESTION
FOR HIM.
>> Harris: ACTUALLY, I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION FOR HIM.
I WANT TO TAKE THE CONVERSATION
A LITTLE FORWARD AS WE AWAIT THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK TO JOIN US.
I WONDER IF HE WILL EVEN TOUCH
ON THIS.
SO, PART OF GOING FORWARD WITH
AN APEX, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
DR. MAKARY, IS NOT JUST ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF CASES AND THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS THAT BREAK OUR
HEARTS EVERY DAY, BUT ALSO THE
NUMBER OF RECOVERIES.
AND THAT IS PARTICULARLY
INTERESTING TO ME TODAY FROM
WHAT I’M READING, THAT THERE IS
THIS PUSH NOW OF BLOOD DRIVES TO
TRY AND FIND PLASMA DONORS, IF
YOU WILL, SO WE CAN LOOK AT
THEIR BLOOD AS A POSSIBLE ANSWER
FOR TREATING AND SUPPORTIVE CARE
FOR SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY SUFFERING THE MOST AMONG
US WITH COVID-19.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
SURVIVORS OF THIS AND HOW THEY
PLAY A ROLE?
>> Dr. Makary: YOU KNOW,
HARRIS, SURVIVORS OF ANY
INFECTIOUS DISEASES HAVE LONG
BEEN AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
CRACKING THE CODE ON HOW TO GET
BEYOND AN INFECTION.
WE SAW IT WITH HIV, LOOSING IT
WITH OTHER INFECTIONS.
99% OF PEOPLE RECOVER FROM
COVID-19 INFECTIONS.
THAT MEANS THERE’S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF DISCHARGES, A LOT OF
RECOVERIES.
AND THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
ANTIBODIES.
THOSE ANTIBODIES ARE ALREADY
BEING EXTRACTED AT HOSPITALS
LIKE MY OWN AND OTHER PLACES.
SO, NOT JUST CAN THOSE
ANTIBODIES BE USED, BUT THEY CAN
BE DUPLICATED IN A LABORATORY TO
TRY AND COME UP WITH A GOOD
THERAPEUTIC.
>> Melissa: I CAN HEAR YOU
NOW, THANK GOODNESS.
IF I COULD FOLLOW ON THAT, ONE
OF THE OTHER STATS I’VE BEEN
HEARING IS THAT OUR VENTURE
LEADER USES DOWN NOW, AS
WELL.
HERE IN NEW YORK, AT LEAST.
WE SEEN A SLIGHT DIP IN THAT.
DOES THAT SAY TO YOU THAT MAYBE
PEOPLE ARE CATCHING THE SYMPTOMS
EARLIER AND MAYBE TAKING BETTER
CARE OF THEMSELVES SO THEY DON’T
GET TO THAT POINT?
HOW WOULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
AND THEN KENNEDY, FEEL FREE TO
GO AHEAD NEXT.
THE SIX I THINK IT SHOWS THAT
SHELTERING IN PLACE
IS WORKING.
I AM PERSONALLY NOT INTERPRETING
THE SLIGHT DECREASE AS A
DECREASE.
I’M INTERPRETING IT AS A
NONSPIKE.
SO I’M NOT FINDING ANY COMFORT
IN ONE OR TWO DAYS OF NUMBERS,
BECAUSE THE DOCTORS ON THE
GROUND ARE TELLING ME THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY BUSY.
THERE WAS A PIECE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JUST
RECENTLY SHOWING THAT MANY
HOSPITALS ARE NOT RECORDING
EVERYTHING.
IT’S NOT THAT THEY ARE
MALICIOUS, IT’S THAT THEY ARE
BUSY.
IF SOMEBODY DIES FROM COVID-19
AND YOU’VE GOT ANOTHER PATIENT
SHORT OF BREATH, YOU GO AND TAKE
CARE OF THEM.